okay okay I'll take care this is your
boy cyka yeah I'll send someone to find
and this is Donald chump and his
henchmen garage let's do this you
shouldn't indulge her Edward it just
makes more impossible to deal with next
time just doing my job speaking of which
here's what we got back the last
delivery from Parsons Raiders got the
rest of it i'm sorry to say oh good
finally this will help settle mother
down Emma Jean is Jack's sister he'd
probably figured that out yourself huh
she's a little flighty impulsive I'm
tired of time she runs off usually with
a new boyfriend I gotcha then I send
somebody to bring her home and she's a
saint for me but its place you know so
I'll bring her back no problem I'll
bring her back the trouble usually isn't
finding her it's persuading her to come
home I don't know where she's gone but I
can give you a place to start she's been
spending a lot of time in good neighbor
hello Jessica all of that place the
third rail somebody there must know
something she's not known for keeping
her mouth shut okay I'll start in good
neighbor cut cut all right let's do this
let's do this like a good day based a
firm is a like a [ __ ] bethesda game a
[ __ ] love screams are 10 years long
you know baby yeah
I need some [ __ ] chicken I got
something this joy you know what I'm
saying mother [ __ ] so I'm shakin I gets
on my lips sometimes I treat them like
when he call those dicks like those
tobacco tabs to chew you know and you
know you hook them into the lip color
tuck them in there I do that with
chicken nuggets that way i'm hungry i
kind of just like dislodge it just chill
you know anyways not for me let's get a
good neighbor okay good and I don't let
a skein god psycho that's a good start
us out I'm at the time when I was
baptized at a dumpster yeah and cows
like let's like with luck okay okay okay
Sarah click save this [ __ ] down stairs
and change that's what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm gonna kill one day hey silver Shui
their smell that come on tell me your
thanks for you too I won't go
this guy the bartender got it no not end
up yeah do you know Emma Jean cabin a
balmy like the Hat on Magnolia every
other phone tell me you didn't like the
song that's an old like jazz not a big
fan of jazz yes sound of battle much
better shame but that's how I ever seen
here good neighbor inspires a certain
kind we're seeing her like oh yeah and
gay knocking out for tea it's your eyes
quick and intense I bet you never miss a
detail hmm you like what you see yes
brings a man like you
the best I came here for a strong
whiskey Charlie will be so it's my turn
to answer so I was wondering if you
could get some go you me who I doing
really well music uh-huh okay sorry sack
Abiquiu happiness you again it's my
lucky day what do you need do you know i
magine Cabot imaging I know tis missing
she's missing I'm glad somebody's
looking at him hmm please tell me what
you know there was this preacher fellow
who used to come in here all the time
sure most of the customers wouldn't give
him the time of day but Emma gee I don't
suppose it hurt that he was easy on the
eyes mmm intense ham did you come over
here a minute how many people are they
gonna call / whose ham their problem is
Magnolia Oh fine gentleman here was just
looking for imaging do you happen to
know where that preacher fella came from
brother Thomas yes that's right the one
Imogene was always hanging had to throw
him out wouldn't stop bothering
customers that salvation I got I got
then he'd shove those stupid flyers in
your face it says here I kept one of
them just in case you didn't pay his bar
tab
anything for you miss I hope even jeans
all right I didn't much like the idea
her going off with that preacher fella
oh yeah Sam Sam she needs to go out with
me and I my way now's my chance to steal
all this stuff you blonde like you blow
my cover here gonna hurry where this guy
comes back I Chad like a hawk and grog
ok the preacher travel there now lets us
kick on west and I what I'm saying got
on west on your path side bye-bye oh
yeah yeah I love a chicken tender right
now a couple to [ __ ] yeah ok tell ya
and to hear you know saying one lucky
shot to the brain but this is what my
speeches due to people
okay West West quick save this [ __ ]
there you go oh that explosion Oh
this guy is lighting shut up scintilla
he'll listen a keeper you know
Jesus is another guy right there my god
in here gut gut gut he's more ammo for
this [ __ ] Jesus
here's that [ __ ]
someone up there no did she just rain
down yeah jesus ok I gotta switch to
this guy cuz I got no [ __ ] ammo ok I
should this guy living this weird thing
and as it's a raft yeah jesus lives in
like this tough coffee yeah yeah five
this [ __ ] f5 this [ __ ] Harley's favor
con birds hey there we are always
looking for new members hey welcome over
we're always glad to see a new face
around here to tell me something you
ever feel like this whole world is
broken mm-hmm you ever wonder why things
can't be the way they were I'm looking
for imaging cabin oh I'm sorry but Emma
Jean is indisposed now she's not seeing
visitors I just need to make sure she's
okay you've got my word she's fine she's
just staying in her room right now not
that it's any of your business but she
sure Jesus seeing any
I'm going to see her one way or another
your choice strong smash this one no you
picked the wrong item hmm switchblade me
these guys don't got nothing good
wow so many suits here baby bottle what
the [ __ ] is a breast feeding them mini
nuke sounds very stank and it's be able
to live it okay you know daddy water
like that
[ __ ]
i didn't realize i think was locked I
didn't open this door Jesus you must be
Emma Jean don't tell me Jack sent you
yep your age that's right I'm here to
rescue you what makes you think I need
to be recognized a nice line what did
you ask to be locked in here no of
course not I could have left whenever I
chose I was just waiting to see if
Thomas would come to his senses he
actually thought it could force me to do
um let's get out of here oh I'm not
going with you you can tell mother I'll
be a long home before too long I just
need a drink first can't until she finds
out that one's dead watch a shady watch
is ready it's gonna be get this to me
good she's like I said it did funny
strong as a scary I guess good that's a
analysis
um I can find my own way home Thanks
okay what do I do now turn to the Kappa
house all right yeah don't you react to
her boyfriend and everyone being
martyred there but i guess not you know
some people are just called you know
I've seen some brothers that I've read
[ __ ] up you know social [ __ ] up
brothers and sisters at seen some really
some real [ __ ] out there you know Jesus
I mean I can't even describe his [ __ ]
and can't i'm talking talking a lot of
pot of sexual stuff just a lot of messes
you know a lot of sick sick messes I
she's in there
I know I doesn't say well faster upline
great not now this is maddening and we
got it over to the Hartley modulator do
you copy Gino how's this oh that's
stunning Edward what's going on there
we're under attack they're inside the
building inside can you keep them out of
the basement I'm trying check I've never
seen Raiders Jesus sorry things are a
little busy around here right now listen
if they're inside the building you have
to go to the office and shut down the
elevator you can't risk them getting to
Lorenzo got it office elevator you
better round up whoever you can
okay what a beast no signal at all I've
lost him what's happening jack if these
people are inside possums if they free
him don't worry I'll handle it I always
knew it within this way I never should
have allowed you to lock up Lorenzo in
that place that isn't helping mother and
as I recall using the serum was your
idea not mine so what are you going to
do I said I'll handle it I'm thinking
who are you again what's going on that
was Edward he's at Parsons the old
they're under attack thanks